en este vídeo quiero aclarar dos ideas
de las que hablamos con bastante
regularidad pero que se mezclan en
nuestro lenguaje común y estas son las
ideas de masa y peso ok entonces vamos a
hablar de lo que es la masa de un objeto
y de lo que es el peso de ese objeto muy
bien y primero les diré que son cada uno
de ellos y luego hablaremos de cómo es
que estos dos conceptos se mezclan ok y
una primera definición de masa que
porque digamos esta definición no es muy
formal pero podríamos pensarlo como la
cantidad de digamos de objetos o de
cosas que tiene algún objeto aunque es
como la cantidad del objeto que del que
estamos hablando muy bien y esto lo
podemos identificar o más o menos
relacionar como con la cantidad de
materia que tiene cierto objeto entonces
uno podría pensar que sí
un objeto del que estamos hablando un
artefacto que estemos viendo o lo que
sea que tengamos a lo mejor en nuestras
manos sí mientras más átomos tenga ese
objeto eso va a implicar que tenga una
mayor masa verdad pero tenemos que ser
muy cuidadosos con esta definición
porque a lo mejor podríamos encontrar
otras cosas que no son digamos lo que
tradicionalmente entendemos por materia
pero que tengan masa pero no nos vamos a
meter con una física muy muy complicada
vamos a dar una definición un poquito
digamos distinta otra forma de pensar la
masa es como como recto bueno podríamos
pensar la masa como como digamos cómo se
mide o cómo reacciona en un objeto ante
una fuerza dada entonces es cómo
reacciona ante una fuerza dada muy bien
y esto lo podemos sacar digamos o pensar
a partir de la segunda ley de newton
verdad porque en la segunda ley de
newton sabemos que la fuerza es igual a
la masa por la aceleración
y entonces la masa digamos sí mientras
más masa tengamos y la fuerza sea fija
quiere decir que la aceleración tiene
que ser menor
ahora si reducimos la masa entonces
nuestra aceleración tiene que ser mayor
por eso es que podríamos pensar a la
masa como una forma de medir cómo
reacciona un objeto ante una fuerza muy
bien ahora ahora por otro lado que bueno
vamos a definir qué es el peso y el peso
es un poco más fácil de definir esto es
esencialmente una fuerza y es la fuerza
de gravedad que actúa sobre un objeto
aunque entonces esto es la fuerza de
gravedad sobre
sobre un objeto
sobre un objeto entonces para pensar
esto podríamos poner el ejemplo de qué
pasa si yo me encuentro parado sobre la
tierra de verdad y de hecho si estoy
parado sobre la tierra si yo estoy sobre
la tierra y de hecho esto es lo
fundamental de la masa no importa donde
me encuentre yo digamos mi masa es
aproximadamente de 70 kilogramos ok
tengo una masa de 70 kilogramos y en un
lenguaje común
a veces podría uno decir que peso no el
70 kilogramos y eso está bien en el
lenguaje común pero técnicamente es
incorrecto es incorrecto en realidad yo
tengo una masa de 70 kilogramos sin
embargo cuál sería entonces mi peso
mi peso aunque y vamos a calcular cuál
sería mi peso dado que tengo una masa de
70 kilogramos nosotros sabemos que el
peso es la fuerza de gravedad que actúa
sobre mi cuerpo digamos y sabemos que la
fuerza es igual a la masa por la
aceleración así que tengo de masa 70
kilogramos y como tengo la fuerza bueno
ya vimos en el vídeo anterior la fuerza
del debido ala a la gravedad que se
calcula de la siguiente forma verdad la
fuerza de gravedad es igual a la
constante de gravitación universal que
es la g mayúscula por la masa 1 por la
masa 1 por la masa 2 verdad porque
estamos calculando la fuerza de
atracción entre dos objetos entonces hay
que multiplicar la primera masa o la
masa del primer objeto por la masa del
segundo objeto y dividirlo entre el
radio 'la pero bueno la distancia al
cuadrado
entonces por ejemplo si yo considero
esta primera masa como la masa de la
tierra digamos la masa de la tierra ok y
digamos que m2 es misma sabes que son
estos 70 kilogramos entonces está r que
sería la distancia sería la distancia
del centro de la tierra digamos del
centro de la tierra a la superficie
a la superficie ok eso es lo que mide
nuestra r verdad y que era la constante
de la gravitación universal entonces al
hacer la multiplicación de estos tres
objetos más bien la multiplicación de g
por m 1 y dividir entre r cuadrada esto
nos da lo que con bueno denotamos en el
vídeo anterior como g minúscula y es una
aceleración de 9.8 metros sobre segundo
al cuadrado y esta es la aceleración que
corresponde a la fuerza de gravedad
sobre la tierra verdad entonces esta
aceleración por la masa o mi masa es lo
que nos da el peso entonces esta es la
masa simplemente hay que multiplicar por
la aceleración que son 9.8 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado y esto qué es lo que
nos da esto nos da pues hay que sacar la
calculadora
son 70 por 9.8 eso nos da 600 86
son 686 kilogramos por metro sobre
segundo al cuadrado y esto de aquí
justamente es lo que conocemos como
newtons verdad
estos son los newtons y que es la unidad
con la que estamos midiendo la fuerza
muy bien entonces esto simplemente nos
da 686 newtons
muy bien ahí lo tienen son 686 newtons
ahora esto por supuesto es mi peso en la
tierra porque el peso depende de donde
me encuentre yo localizado por ejemplo
si yo quisiera calcular cuál sería mi
peso en la luna mi peso en la luna
en la luna
estaba yo leyendo en internet por
supuesto lo están leyendo antes de
preparar el vídeo que el peso sobre la
luna de cualquier objeto es
aproximadamente una sexta parte de lo
que pesa en la tierra entonces más o
menos sería un sexto de lo que peso en
la tierra que son 686 newtons y esto nos
da que sería como siento algo así como
114 a ver vamos a ver 686 entre 6 nos da
si 114 más o menos 114 newtons entonces
lo fundamental y que por eso me gustó
este ejemplo es que hay que tener
cuidado ya que el peso cambia
dependiendo de dónde estemos localizados
sin embargo la masa no cambia nunca es a
esa masa se mantiene constante de hecho
si nosotros nos cambiamos de planeta o
si a lo mejor nos encontramos en otra
altura o es más incluso podríamos estar
localizados en algún otro lugar de la
tierra recordemos que aunque la tierra
siempre la pensamos
una esfera bueno déjenme hacer un mejor
dibujo en realidad la tierra es como una
especie de esfera achatada verdad como
una especie de
y soy de aunque este no es el mejor
dibujo pero más o menos espero que quede
claro lo que quiero representar a la
tierra no es una esfera perfecta es más
o menos achatada así que la distancia al
centro de la tierra por ejemplo si
estamos en alguno de los polos será
mucho menor que si estamos localizados
sobre el ecuador ok entonces el peso
dependerá también de dónde estemos
localizados en la tierra muy bien
lo importante de aquí es que aunque
podría cambiar el peso lo que sí se
mantiene constante es la masa aunque la
masa no cambia
nunca cambie que no importa donde
estemos localizados ahora a lo mejor tú
alguna vez habrás oído en no sé a lo
mejor cuando vas a comprar algo en el
bueno quizás en el mercado no pero en
algún no sé no sé a lo mejor en alguna
caja de cereal o en algún artículo que
compras que tiene un peso lo que sea que
hayas comprado de a lo mejor por decir
un número de 160 libras
ok 160 libras y de hecho las libras es
una unidad de medida pero del sistema
inglés muy bien este no es del sistema
digamos internacional si si digamos que
tú en contraste un artículo que tiene un
peso de 160 libras
bueno digamos el lenguaje común uno se
preguntaría bueno en realidad las libras
son una unidad de peso o es una unidad
de masa y la respuesta correcta es que
las libras en efecto es una unidad de
peso entonces uno se pregunta bueno
cuáles serían las unidades para la masa
en el sistema inglés y estas unidades se
llaman slot ok él es lo que él es lo que
es como la la unidad de medida de masa
en el sistema inglés entonces si
nosotros tenemos que el peso es de 160
libras 160 libras esto debe ser igual a
la aceleración y esa aceleración en el
sistema inglés se mide como 32 pies 32
32 pies sobre segundo al cuadrado esto
es lo mismo que 9.8 metros sobre el
segundo al cuadrado simplemente que
convertimos los metros a pies
entonces esto es 32 pies sobre segundo
al cuadrado y que multiplica a la masa
verdad esto es simplemente por la
segunda ley de newton y esta masa le
estamos midiendo ahora en es logs muy
bien
entonces qué es lo que hacemos para
calcular cuál es la masa pues
simplemente dividimos de ambos lados
entre treinta y dos pies sobre segundo
al cuadrado dividimos de ambos lados
al cuadrado todo esto se cancela y lo
que me queda es dividir 160 entre 32 y
qué es lo que nos da 160 sobre 32 y esto
nos da 5 exactamente 5 entonces tenemos
5 libras
aquí déjenme hacerlo con el mismo color
tenemos 5 libras 5 libras por segundo al
cuadrado / pie muy bien entre pies y
esto es exactamente la masa pero medida
en es looks en slots perdón eso quiere
decir que esto extraño que tenemos aquí
son justamente los tres logs así es como
podríamos definir los slots entonces
espero que en este vídeo te haya ayudado
un poco para aclarar los conceptos o la
diferencia de los conceptos entre masa y
peso